even democrats tonight they're starting
to come clean about
joe biden's obvious cognitive struggles
just take a look at this article from
the ap about congressman mondaire jones
and the recent interaction that he had
with president sippy cup
he said quote he told president joe
biden that their party needed
him more involved in passing voting
legislation on the hill
in response he said biden just sort of
stared at me jones said describing an
awkward silence that passed between the
two
now the ap described this as quote a
lackluster
engagement let me translate that joe
biden
is checked out he's cognitively weak
he's weak physically he's weak mentally
he's a cognitive mess
even his own party is starting to admit
the obvious
still don't believe me just watch sippy
cup
and his remarks earlier today on gun
control take a look
the blood of patriots you know and all
the stuff about how we're going to have
to
move against the government while the
tree of liberty is not water in the
blood of patriots what's happened is
that there are never been if you wanted
to think you need to
have weapons to take on the government
you need f-15s and maybe some
nuclear weapons police chief murray of
the baltimore
uh excuse me police chief mayor
police chief murphy paul
of baton rouge louisiana it means
confirming my
outstanding nominee for to lead the aft
they assume the atf david chipman
they'll tell you there's no possible
justification for having a hundred
rounds in a magazine of a gun
like i've said before what do you think
the deer wearing kepar vest
does that seem like someone with the
energy alertness
mental uh capacity to be president of
the united states that's the hardest job
in the world because i've got to be
honest
a lot of this isn't even funny anymore
pretty serious here with the reaction
louisiana senator john kennedy senator
to me this is not a matter of joe's age
i'll give you an example bernie sanders
bernie sanders is as sharp as he was
20 years ago pushing his radical
socialism communism whatever he was
pushing at the time
he has energy he's alert he's articulate
he has passion in what he does you see
the president every day
i'm playing these tapes every night uh
it's an
obvious problem it seems degenerative
i would assume the pressures of the
office might accelerate whatever's going
on here
dr ronnie jackson thinks he needs a
cognitive test
what are your thoughts well sean i
listened to the president's
press conference today
and and there were times when i was
confused
let me speak to the substance though i
don't hate anyone
but whoever is advising the president on
crime
and i don't know who it is but whoever
it is
his um his secret service name ought to
be butt head
i mean why has chicago become the
world's
largest outdoor shooting range why is it
safer to walk down the streets
of mogadishu than new york city
crime is not up as the president seemed
to indicate
today because of inadequate background
checks
crime is up because many not all but
many members
of the president's own party believe in
defunding the police
they ran on it and in many cities
they've done it
crime is up because many members of the
president's own party want to turn cops
into social workers
crime is up because many members of the
president's own party think all cops
are racists including apparently the
african-american police officers
crime is up because many members of the
president's own party
think that when a cop shoots a criminal
it's always the cops fault but when a
criminal
shoots a cop it's always the gun's fault
now most people in america know that and
we're not going to get in
in control of this crime situation until
we do three things
until president biden does three things
number one fund the police
give them their money back number two
let cops be cops let them do their job
now if if if they misbehave
if they don't follow the law punish them
hold them accountable like we did with
derrick chauvin but most cops follow the
law
and number three we're going to have to
do what mayor giuliani and mayor
bloomberg did in new york city and we're
going to have to do it in all the the
major crime years
we're going to have to bring back stop
question and frisk
and apply it in a racially neutral
manner it is
perfectly legal it has been used for
years
chief justice earl warren wrote the
opinion in 1968
a case called terryv ohio that says it
is perfectly
legal to stop questioning and frisk if
you do it in a racially neutral manner
and until we do though i mean this
business of
the confusion from the press conference
and this business of
background checks and
i mean it's just drivel and i think most
americans know it let me let me ask
as as you see crime in all of these
cities
and and you see uh for example we just
had in new york an announcement that all
the people that were involved in
arson all the people involved in looting
people we
we have videotapes of them doing these
committing these crimes
none of them are going to be prosecuted
you have defunding the police you have
dismantling the police and you have no
bail laws taking over in the country
i don't know senator i'm just a simple
guy i'm just a little talk show host
i just don't see any of that ending well
i like to ask people the question
if we dismantle defund the police what
are you going to do
if god forbid somebody breaks into your
home late at night
senator i i'm pretty sure that you have
a plan
i know i have my plan uh i'm not going
to be counting on other people to
protect me in my life
but most people don't have a plan and
many people aren't capable of
even even following up on a plan if they
did have one
well how can i put this you remember
you remember how you felt you remember
how people panicked
when they couldn't find toilet paper
imagine how they're going to feel when
they can't find a cop
and that's where that's where we're
headed here uh
this attitude among many not all but
many of my democratic colleagues
that we can we can have order
without justice that we can have order
without
law enforcement is is
nonsense i don't know where it came from
unfortunately i don't know why but there
are people in this world
they're not mixed up they're not
confused they're they're not sick
it's not a question of whether their
mama or daddy loved them enough
they're just anti-social and society's
got to be protected and we've got to
have cops to do
i it i can't say it any more simply uh
you've done a great job for the people
of louisiana senator we're supporting
and following closely your re-election
race in 2022 thank you for being with us